يوم عصيب على النفط الروسي ففي الخامس من
ديسمبر 2022 واجه هذا القطاع الاستراتيجي
قرارين مؤلمين متزامين لقد بدا سريان
مفعول قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول مجموعه
السبع الصناعيه الكبرى واستراليا القاضي
باعتماد مبلغ 60 دولارا سعرا اقصى لبرميل
الخام الروسي كما دخل حيز التنفيذ قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي حذرا نفط الروسي المنقول
بحرا وهو ما سيلغى فعليا وفوريا ثلثي
والدتي دول الاتحاد منه اما تحديد سعر
فيترتب عليه عدم السماحي لاي جهه او شركه
بنقل اي نفط روسي يتخطى السعر المحدد كما
تتطلع الدول صاحبه القرار الى تعميم هذا
السقف السعر على معظم زبائن روسي عبر
العالم ومن بينهم الصين والهند
يهدف القراران لا تقليس ايرادات موسكو
الماليه الهائله من مبيعات النفط وبالتالي
الى النيل من قدرته على تمويل حربها على
اوكرانيا مع الحفاظ على تدفق نفسها الى
الاسواق العالميه فسعر 60$ للبرميل يظل
اعلى بكثير من تكلفه الانتاج الحاليه في
روسيا مما يحفزها على الاستمرار في ضخام
وجني عائدات تحتاجها بالحاح في مواجهه
الخطوات الغربيه اعلن المتحدث باسم
الكربلاند ديميتر بيسكوف ان بلاده لن
تعترف باي سقف باسعار الطاقه وانها ستتخذ
تدابير للرد معتبرا النتيجه القرارات لن
تؤثر على المجهود الحربي الروسي في
اوكرانيا وستؤدي فقط الى مزيد من زعزعه
استقرار سوق الطاقه العالمي على حد قوله
لكن التصريحات السياسيه قد لا تتطابق
دائما مع الحقائق الاقتصاديه في روسيا هي
ثاني اكبر مصدر للنفط الخام في العالم واي
عقوبات ستؤثر حتما على هذا القطاع الذي
تزداد الحاجه اليه جر الحرب وحلول فصل
الشتاء
الاسواق ايضا كان ردها سريعا حيث قفزت
اسعار الخام نحو ثلاثه في المئه بعد ان
ابقى دول وبيك بلاس على العمل باتفاق
اكتوبر الماضي الذي ينص على خفض الانتاج
بمقدار مليونير بربيلي يوميا بدايه من
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي وحتى نهايه
العام المقبل